[Musik]
und jetzt das heute-journal
fliegerhorst wunstorf früher abend heute
eine nach der anderen schweben die
transportmaschinen der bundesluftwaffe
ein aus kabul und taschkent bringen die
soldaten zurück die tausende menschen
aus kabul rausgeholt haben ist es nicht
mehr ging die allermeisten von den
wahren afghanische hilfe
das war ein eindrucksvoller
erfolgreicher humanitärer einsatz dieses
letzte kapitel
guten abend so geht deutschlands teil
einer historischen mission zu ende
historisch es war das erste mal dass die
nato den verteidigungsfall für das
bündnis ausgerufen hatte das größte
militärbündnis der geschichte und der
einsatz endete in einer niederlage aber
so sollte es nicht aussehen heute abend
diesmal nicht die verantwortlichen
hatten die chance soldatinnen und
soldaten zu danken hier schon einmal
peinlich verpasst da war es wieder
gutzumachen
thomas reichert berichtet es ist ein
bittersüßer haben dass die
militärmaschinen heute um kurz vor 20
uhr aus afghanistan zurückkehren zurück
von einer höchst gefährlichen mission
bei der sie viele gerettet haben und
noch mehr zurücklassen mussten die
verteidigungsministerin spricht von
großem vertrauen in die evakuierungs
truppe und ihrem kommandeur die diese
voll erfüllt hätten dafür bin ich ihnen
persönlich zutiefst dankbar und wir alle
in deutschland
stehen ihnen und den männern und frauen
der bundeswehr ihres einsatzverbandes
gegenüber in einer ganz tiefen schuld es
ist ein großer empfang ganz anders als
vor zwei monaten
damals ende juni waren in wunstorf weder
die verteidigungsministerin noch die
kanzlerin da als nach 20 jahren einsatz
das letzte deutsche
afghanistan-kontingent zurückkehrte
ich durchhalte kommandeur für sie
verstellen mission accomplished
aber die mission war gerade nicht
erfüllt die vielleicht gefährlich sie
sollte erst noch kommen die rettung von
menschen aus den händen der taliban
stand heute hat die bundeswehr
5347 menschen aus mindestens 45 ländern
ausgeflogen darunter rund 500 deutsche
und mehr als 4000 afghan doch das
bittere dieses tages ist viele wurden
nicht gerettet wurden zurückgelassen wir
gehen im moment davon aus dass etwa 300
deutsche sich noch in afghanistan
befinden und wir hatten stand gestern
über 10.000 afghanische staatsangehörige
erfasst die zur teilnahme an der
evakuierung
identifiziert worden waren die frage in
berlin ist nun hätten noch mehr menschen
gerettet werden können hat die
bundesregierung zu spät reagiert im
auswärtigen amt geht am 6 18 tage vor
dem ersten evakuierungs flug ein draht
bericht der deutschen botschafterin in
washington ein eine kopie geht auch ans
verteidigungsministerium
der bericht ist vertraulich doch einige
abgeordneten wissen mehr es gibt
ernsthafte hinweise darauf dass dieser
bericht über planungen der vereinigten
staaten spricht mehrere tausend soldaten
an den flughafen nach caputh zu verlegen
also ganz deutliche indizien dass die
vereinigten staaten evakuieren operation
vorbereitet haben in deutschland
beginnen laut einem papier des
verteidigungsministeriums erster
zwölften achten die ersten planungen zur
evakuierung der erste flug ist am 16 08
die ministerin hat letztlich den befehl
erst letzten sonntag gegeben also vor
neun tagen
und wir sagen er hätte drei tage vorher
gegeben werden können drei kostbare tage
die verloren gegangen sind und die unter
umständen ortskräfte die gewartet haben
und deutsche staatsbürger die nicht raus
kam schwerst gefährden wenn ich sogar
das leben kostet auswärtiges amt und
verteidigungsministerium
dementieren gegenüber dem zdf die
vorwürfe erklären es habe zitat keine
konkreten operation ankündigung der usa
gegeben
der einsatz ist heute zwar zu ende
gegangen die fragen aber beginnen nun
der bundeswehr ist es gelungen alle ihre
verbliebenen soldaten und mehr als 4000
afghanische helfer ohne verluste aus dem
land zu bringen insofern mission
accomplished
eine beachtliche leistung
aber die etwa
150000 soldatinnen soldaten die zum teil
mehrfach in afghanistan gedient haben
sind dort ja nicht hingegangen um eines
tages unversehrt nach hause zu kommen
und das land ansonsten den taliban zu
überlassen insofern mission nicht
komplett viele haben sich immer wieder
vom parlament regierung und
öffentlichkeit im stich gelassen gefühlt
das ist auch in den letzten tagen
deutlich geworden der cdu abgeordnete
roderich kiesewetter kennt afghanistan
von innen und von außen beide seiten als
ehemaliger oberst im generalstab und als
obmann der union im auswärtigen
ausschuss guten abend herr kiesewetter
guten abend herr kleber wir haben eine
schlimme verzögerung die frage wie viel
wut und enttäuschung steckt in ihnen
heute abend
es steckt schon bitterkeit in mir weil
ich einmal die lage vor ort viele jahre
begleitet habe und auf der anderen seite
in meinen ersten vier jahren im
parlament auch immer mahnen auf
notwendige anpassungen des mandats
hingewiesen habe aber ich bin auf der
anderen seite sehr froh dass unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten über 20 jahre
den parlamentarischen auftrag voll
erfüllt haben 59 kameraden in und
kameraden haben ihr leben verloren viele
hundert wurden verletzt dennoch das ende
hätte anders sein können die amerikaner
haben uns zu spät von ihrem abzug
informiert und das muss auch
aufgearbeitet werden unabhängig von
innenpolitischen fragen es ist eine
entscheidende bündnisfrage denn die nato
war dort im einsatz und nicht die usa
und deutschland allein nun hatte es aber
auch situationen gegeben in denen
deutsche soldaten immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen haben dass sie einfach nicht
das richtige mandat haben dass sie dinge
die militärisch notwendig waren nicht
arm machen durften weil sie gehemmt
waren durch entsprechende mandate und
durch entsprechend beschränkte
ausstattung mit waffen material usw das
ist eine geschichte von 20 jahren die
nie zu ende gegangen ist sie haben das
als abgeordneter mitbekommen
ich habe es nicht nur als abgeordneter
mitbekommen sondern auch vor ort in
einer schwierigen lage in kundus auf
einer dienstreise und habe auch erlebt
die deutsche generalität moniert hat
aber die politik hat es damals so nicht
hören wollen denn das narrativ war
friedlicher wiederaufbau und die
entscheidende lehre ist dass wir keinen
politisch wünschenswert wünschenswerten
einsatz leisten dürfen sondern eine
nüchterne analyse der deutschen
interessen bewerten müssen und vor allen
dingen die soldatinnen und soldaten
ausstatten müssen mit dem was sie
brauchen dazu gehören bewaffnete drohnen
dazu gehören auch flugzeuge die waffen
einsetzen dürfen all das war lange jahre
nicht gewünscht dass wir erst in den
letzten jahren aber da war es zu spät
wir müssen uns als land und auch das
parlament vorwerfen lassen nicht auf die
stimmen der soldaten rechtzeitig gehört
zu haben aber auch wir im parlament die
uns als anwalt der soldatinnen und
soldaten fühlen hatten oft den eindruck
dass es schlichtweg darum ging das
narrativ vom friedlichen wiederaufbau zu
verteidigen und nicht stark auch die
interessen der bevölkerung im sinne
eines politischen und auch militärischen
schutzes dort zu leisten hier war viel
wünschenswertes und die nüchterne
realität die auch der bundeswehrverband
immer wieder ansprach wurde schlichtweg
verdrängt die deutschen soldaten haben
zum schluss sich ganz wesentlich auf
ausbildung konzentriert haben mitgewirkt
an der ausbildung von hunderttausenden
von afghanen zu afghanischen soldaten
die in der lage sind ihr land selbst zu
verteidigen wie konnte es sein dass
diese ausbilder nie mitbekommen haben
dass er eine armee heranziehen die
keinerlei kampfeswillen hat die im
ersten augenblick wenn die gehälter
nicht mehr gezahlt werden und der krieg
beginnt die waffen von sich werfen und
aufgeben
das hat zumindest zwei ursachen zum
einen durften die deutschen soldaten die
amerika die afghanischen kameraden nie
in den einsatz begleiten sie wurden auf
die einsätze vorbereitet aber das mandat
hat keine einsatz begleitung vorgesehen
weil die in der regel im süden
afghanistans war und das war für uns
verboten weil eben hier im norden
eingesetzt waren zweitens und das ist
glaube ich genauso wichtig
insgesamt wiederaufbau fehlte
schlichtweg die bewertung ob die
regierung rückhalt in der bevölkerung
hat und die regierung galt egal in
welcher ausgestaltung als korrupt
deshalb ist es so entscheidend dass wir
bei für künftige mandate so wie wir das
auch vorsehen eine evaluierung der
einsätze machen die einsatz fortschritte
messen und nach steuern und dies fand
zwar immer wieder in der debatte als
forderung statt von mir und vielen
kolleginnen und kollegen aber wir müssen
uns als parlament stärken und brauchen
von der regierung eine jährliche
evaluierung unsere auslandseinsätze um
solche missstände zu vermeiden und auch
um zu erkennen wie loyal denn die sind
die wir unterstützen ob sie die
unterstützung überhaupt wollen und
deshalb muss das ständig nachgebessert
und auch bewertet werden und eben nicht
immer nur das politisch wünschenswerte
betrachtet es gab eine situation gestern
abend wo der unterschied zwischen der
bundeswehr und der amerikanischen
streitmacht ganz deutlich wurde bei den
anschlägen vor den toren des flughafens
hat der amerikanische general zwölf
seiner soldatinnen und soldaten verloren
er ist da geblieben die deutsche
bundesluftwaffe im inneren des
flughafens nicht unmittelbar betroffen
hat den abbruch der mission verkündet
und ist so schnell wie möglich weg
geflogen general mehr kennen sie der
amerikaner sagte dann hinterher wir
hatten von pfarrer ein verein für eine
evakuierungsaktion geplant die unter
militärische bedrohung stattfindet da
passieren solche dinge wir machen weiter
und wir machen bis heute weiter wollen
sie eine bundeswehr die in diesem sinne
ihren charakter ändert
nein ich will aber ein bündnispartner
der frühzeitig seine bündnispartner
informiert was unsere tapferen
soldatinnen und soldaten dort unter
schwierigsten umständen geleistet haben
verdient allerhöchste anerkennung und
wertschätzung in der bevölkerung ich
hoffe dass damit endlich die notwendige
gesellschaftliche debatte angestoßen
wird dass unsere gesellschaft hinter den
streitkräften steht und zwar nicht nur
bei hochwasser
und waldmann katastrophen sondern in
schwierigen einsätzen und die bundeswehr
war nicht dafür ausgestattet diesem
flughafen zu sichern armin laschet hat
selbst letztes wochenende gefordert die
bundeswehr muss künftig in der lage sein
sich selbst zu schützen dazu gehören
bewaffnete drohnen aber auch viel mehr
nämlich eine viel bessere einbindung
auch in den entscheidungsprozess der
bündnispartner und wir dürfen einsätze
künftig nur machen wenn wir selbst
eigene interessen vor ort haben und
diese interessen auch militärisch
durchsetzen
deshalb war die entscheidung von general
art den einsatz so zu beenden absolut
richtig weil wir nicht die ausstattung
hatten um einen kampfeinsatz vor ort
noch über mehrere tage durchzuhalten
danke herr kiesewetter dieser einsatz
ist vorüber die debatte darüber darf es
nicht sein einen guten abend ihnen noch
die aufgabe den aussichtslos gewordenen
krieg zu beenden landet bei us präsident
joe biden sie bringt ihm die
schwierigsten tage seiner amtszeit
bisher und er kann nur beten dass nicht
noch schwierigere kommen vielleicht
schon morgen das rüttelt an den
fundamenten seiner präsidentschaft
claudia bates verfolgt das in
washington für die toten der präsident
angeschlagen in jeder hinsicht er betont
sein mitgefühl mit den familien der
gefallenen soldaten doch in der sache
bleibt beiden klar die mission läuft
weiter wie geplant der krieg muss
beendet werden trotzdem wird es
vergeltung geben
an die diesen angriff ausgeführt haben
und alle die amerika schaden wollen wir
werden nicht vergeben wir werden nicht
vergessen wir werden euch jagen und ihr
werdet dafür bezahlen
doch zunächst drohen weitere terrorakte
sagen beiden sicherheitsberater hier in
kabul am flughafen wo heute am ort des
anschlags eine gespenstische leere
herrschte die taliban schieben die
schuld für den terror den usa und ihren
verbündeten zu
sie haben die menschen zur ausreise
ermuntert und sie bewachen den
gesperrten flughafen für uns ist das
sehr schwer 10.000 menschen vor dem
flughafen zu kontrollieren das ist ein
großes problem
vor den krankenhäusern hoffen
verzweifelte angehörige dass ihre lieben
drin überleben während den ganzen tag
über särge transportiert werden die
afghanen begraben ihre toten die usa
trauern um die iren
und während in der washingtoner sonne
die flaggen auf halbmast wehen werden im
pentagon pläne entworfen für den von
beiden befohlenen gegenschlag amerika
kämpft also wieder gegen den terrorismus
aus afghanistan wie vor 20 jahren
wir werden wieder reingehen müssen um
den es zu kriegen und auch wenn sich al
qaida in afghanistan wieder formiert und
das werden sie wir können ein
schlachtfeld verlassen aber nicht den
krieg gegen den terrorismus
die opposition im parlament ruft
reiserücktritt laut ruft sie erstmal der
präsident habe versagt die abrechnung
dafür werden noch folgen das ist nicht
die führungsstärke die der präsident
versprochen hat es ist schwäche und
unfähigkeit um oberbefehlshaber zu sein
braucht man das zutrauen das vertrauen
und den glauben an ihn in der
amerikanischen bevölkerung präsident
biden hat gestern alle drei verloren
aber vor der abrechnung kommt die
mission und die geht weiter während fast
alle verbündeten ihre rettungsflüge
eingestellt haben bringen die us flieger
weiter täglich tausende aus dem
zerrütteten land
nachrichten nun von gundula gause
mehr investitionen in afrika vor allem
im bereich erneuerbarer energie und
einen ausbau der impfstoffproduktion auf
dem kontinent darum ging es bei einer
konferenz einer afrika initiative der
deutschen wirtschaft dazu empfängt
bundeskanzlerin merkel in berlin rund
ein dutzend afrikanischer staats und
regierungschefs ihnen sagte sie
weiterhin deutsche unterstützung zu auch
um die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
pandemie auf dem kontinent abzufedern
die konferenz heute war zugleich eine
art abschied merkels als kanzlerin von
afrika
angesichts steigender corona zahlen
prüft die bundesregierung die anwendung
der 3g regeln für den fernverkehr
damit könnten künftig nur noch geimpfte
genesene oder negativ getestet fernzüge
und inlandsflüge nutzen spanien und
portugal hauptstadt lissabon werden ab
sonntag von der hochrisiko liste
gestrichen damit entfallen die
quarantänevorschriften für von dort
rückkehrende das robert koch institut
registrierte
12.000 29 neuinfektionen binnen eines
tages
2749 mehr als vor einer woche 14
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incidents ist auf 70,3 gestiegen
der frühere vize kanzler österreichs
heinz christian strache ist wegen
bestechlichkeit zu 15 monaten haft auf
bewährung verurteilt worden der frühere
spd-chef hat laut urteil zugunsten einer
privatklinik einfluss auf ein gesetz
genommen im gegenzug seien parteispenden
an die rechte fpö geflossen strache
bestritt diese vorwürfe bis zuletzt
seine verteidiger kündigten berufung an
die linkspartei hat in rostock ihre
bundesweite wahlkampftour begonnen bei
der auftaktveranstaltung war das spitzen
duo janine wissler und dietmar bartsch
für eine mögliche regierungsbeteiligung
der linken kernforderungen der partei
sind unter anderem höhere steuern für
wohlhabende und eine mindestrente
nach aktuellen prognosen müssen die
linken aber um ihren einzug in den
bundestag bangen im aktuellen zdf
politbarometer liegt die partei nur
knapp über der fünf prozent hürde in
vier wochen und zwei tagen werden
wählerinnen und wähler über die
besetzung von bundestag und kanzleramt
entscheiden bis dahin wird nun
wöchentlich ein zdf politbarometer die
stimmung im land messen
sonderlich heiß fühlt sich dieser
wahlkampf nicht an aber die temperatur
hat immerhin dazu geführt dass der
vorsprung des kandidaten laschet und
seiner cdu weggeschmolzen sind wie
eisbecher an der sonne so hat horst
seehofer mal ein ähnliches schicksal
eines anderen cdu-mannes kommentiert
parteilich gesehen hat die spd bei uns
im politbarometer jetzt erstmals mit der
union gleichgezogen
persönlich gesehen als erste wahl für
das kanzleramt sagt spd-mann scholz
schon beinahe turmhaus hochhaus mit 49
prozent gegenüber 17 für laschet und 16
für werbung das ist kein wahlergebnis
das ist stimmung in zahlen zahlen die
die stimmung an der cdu-basis verhageln
könnten dort ist dort ferber unterwegs
in la chaise bundesland nordrhein
westfalen
es ist der wahlkampfauftakt der cdu in
wuppertal
das wetter ist trübe und die stimmung
irgendwie auch cdu und spd gleichauf man
spricht sich selbst mut zu
ich denke mir ist es eine momentaufnahme
das kann sich in der von wenigen tagen
ganz anders wieder entwickeln braucht
muss man irgendetwas wurde spd nicht
optimal laufen ein wahlkampfes ein auf
und ab und von daher wäre noch viel zeit
das blatt wieder zu drehen aber die zeit
läuft und es gibt hier manche zweifel am
eigenen spitzenkandidaten der habe
fehler gemacht
nicht mehr passieren das sind halt
sachen die kommen bei jungen leuten auch
ganz komisch an im internet wird das
dann zu - weiter entwickelt sind in
letzter zeit ein paar sachen schief
gegangen ich denke man hat keine klaren
inhalte vermitteln können es war alles
so ein bisschen wacklig auch grad die
performance während der
hochwasserkatastrophe
von umfragewerten unbeirrt zeigt sich
armin laschet heute noch ein westfalens
ministerpräsident stellt seine fluthilfe
pläne vor sein krisenmanagement in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung hat ihm das
nicht geholfen ich weiß nicht wie die
öffentlichkeit wahrnimmt ich die
menschen bei denen ich bin vor ort
nehmen wahr dass die landesregierung
hier handelt
und zwar entschlossen handelt
entschlossenes handeln das erwarten sie
in der union jetzt von ihrem
kanzlerkandidaten
der wahlkampf hat schließlich begonnen
auch im csu land bayern hier wäre der
wunschkandidat söder gewesen nun ist es
laschet was tun also es klappt das
problem ist einfach dass er
sich unbeliebt gemacht hat der
bevölkerung ich weiß nicht ob man das
möglichst so schnell innerhalb von einem
monat wieder hinkriegen könnte der
müsste im wahlkampf aktiv werden und
entsprechende statements linien
der ministerpräsident
hat ja gesagt dass er schulter an
schulter mit laschet kämpft da muss auch
mehr getan werden
zurück nach wuppertal
hier ist inzwischen ein populärer
wahlkämpfer eingetroffen nordrhein
westfalens innenminister herbert reul
setzt auf einem team verlassen rudert
reist nie eine alleine rum sondern es
kommt darauf an was in den nächsten
tagen und wochen für die menschen
wichtig ist ob sie jetzt noch weiter
darüber diskutieren auch bei
ministerpräsident lachten oder nicht
macht oder ob sie darüber reden wie die
gesellschaft von morgen aussehen soll es
ist ihre hoffnung hier es müsste mehr um
die inhalte gehen und weniger an die
person
wie soll man diese zahlen verstehen das
ist gut karl rudolf korte hierzu haben
kein orakel der politikwissenschaftler
unseres vertrauens herr korte da hat
sich ja mordsmäßig was verschoben in
diesem wahlkampf warum es hat ja keine
der parteien oder keiner der kandidaten
irgendwas revolutionär neues gesagt oder
getan zwar her aber im moment stehen
überall die wahlplakate überall werden
die wahlbenachrichtigungen verschickt
also die dringlichkeit sich selbst zu
entscheiden dem zu und das bewusstsein
dass erstmals keine kanzlerkandidatin
zur verfügung steht und das führt
automatisch dazu dass die drei parteien
die kanzlerkandidaten benannt haben an
der startlinie wie drei halbstarke um 20
prozent herum stehen und die gleichen
chancen haben das ist jetzt durch den
zeitfaktor wenige wochen vor der wahl
eine erwartbare konstellation angesichts
dieser historischen einmaligkeit keine
kandidaten keine kanzlerin als
kandidatin zu haben aber dann gab es ja
diese enorme verschiebung dass wir jetzt
16 und 17 prozent für bernburg und
laschet haben und 49 prozent für olaf
scholz baby ist dieser trifft in dieser
einrichtung gekommen es hängt damit
zusammen dass einmal die orientierung
auf die frage wen man dieses vertrauen
was man merkel übertragen hat dann
vielleicht widmen kann dass merkel legte
sicherheits vertrauen wird olaf scholz
entgegen gebracht er hat auch die
bundespolitische erfahrung die die
anderen beiden nicht mit ein und
insofern findet sich die situation dass
man dieser person eben besonders
vertraut und den anderen weniger es
liegt auch gar nicht so sehr an den
einzelnen fehlern es liegt auch bei der
union vor allen dingen daran dass sich
auch bestimmte
kurve und des regierens auch verändern
lebens kurven ein countdown des macht
vorfalls nach 16 jahren einsetzen kann
den man natürlich noch aufhalten kann
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt aber besondere
mechanismen braucht was sind das denn
für besondere mechanismen sie meinen
keinen zauberstab oder nein aber nach 16
jahren fragt man sich warum wird man
noch gebraucht also eine
selbsterneuerung in der regel über
person also ein team mit neuen
gesichtern dass auch das neue
dokumentiert und nicht einfach ein
weiter so und eine agenda des vorsorge
staates um den wir ja alle ringen wer
hat das rezept für einen schützenden
lenkenden vorsorge statt also brauchen
wir auch ein thema mit dem man sich
beschäftigt anzugreifen nicht nur eine
möglichkeit na ja eigentlich kein
wohlfühl wahlkampf nicht die gegner
nieder schmusen sondern durchaus mit
einem angebot ein thema setzen eine
führungs erzählung setzen das ist für
die parteien in den letzten tagen extrem
wichtig die dieser enorme vorsprung für
olaf scholz ist er kein vorsprung für
die spd und auf dem wahlzettel steht ja
nicht olaf scholz dasteht spd kann es
sein dass sich das am ende dann doch
noch irgendwie ganz anders ausdrückt
wenn die leute in der wahlkabine sind
nach historischer verein denn natürlich
sind die weder erstmal parteien wähler
haben der partei identifikation nicht
personenbezogen sehr stark aber sie sind
nach wie vor in der richtung wie sie
sich jetzt an deuten bei der person die
das merkel lege sicherheitsgefühl
verkörpert wir werden sehen vier wochen
sind andererseits noch eine ewigkeit in
der politik sollte man danke schön herr
korte und hier geht es wieder weiter mit
nachrichten gundula
das thema an den internationalen
finanzmärkten war zu diesem
wochenschluss die us notenbankkonferenz
in jackson hole von der wichtige signale
für die geldpolitik in den usa und
europa erwartet wurden ein signal dass
fed chef paul gab war das der beruhigung
stephanie barron ist das nicht aber
irritierend angesichts der hohen
inflation in den usa ja das stimmte und
die amerikanische notenbank gibt sich im
hinblick auf das thema inflation ganz
offensichtlich deutlich entspannter als
man denken würde seit beginn der
pandemie leistet die fed der us
wirtschaft krisenhilfe mit dem aufkauf
von anleihen im volumen von 120
milliarden us dollar pro monat das hat
die us amerikanische wirtschaft wieder
ins laufen gebracht sie wächst mit 6,6
prozent wieder kräftig und damit auch
stärker als die europäische entsprechend
könnte die fed ihre stützungskäufe auch
allmählich wieder zurückfahren denn die
erhitzte us konjunktur lässt auch die
preise steigen so erreichte die
inflation im juli einen rekordwert von
5,4 prozent
das ist mehr als doppelt so viel wie in
der eu doch jerome paul chef der us
notenbank betonte heute bei seiner
virtuellen rede man liege mit der
geldpolitik im plan die hohe inflation
sei ein chor über gehendes phänomen
frühestens ende des jahres kündigte er
einen sehr behutsamen einstieg in den
ausstieg aus der lockeren geldpolitik an
einen zeitplan vermied er denn die
ausbreitung der delta variante des
corona virus bereitet noch sorgen
dennoch zeigten sich die finanzmärkte
von den signalen erleichtert der dax
legte zu und schloss mit einem plus von
58 punkten auf wochensicht zeigt sich
der index allerdings kaum verändert für
sparer bedeutet der heutige tag die
zinsen bleiben vorerst bei 0% sie müssen
weiterhin nach gewinnbringenden anlagen
suchen fielen dann stefanie nach
frankfurt fußball superstar ronaldo
steht vor einem spektakulären wechsel
zurück der 36 jahre alte portugiese geht
von juventus turin zurück zum manchester
united wo er schon von 2003 an sechs
jahre lang spielte als ablöse wird die
summe von rund 25 millionen euro
gehandelt nach medizin check und anderen
formalitäten soll der vertrag
unterzeichnet werden auch in diesem
jahre beklagen die bauern eine
überwiegend enttäuschende ernte messe
hagel und zu wenig sonne haben vor allem
dem getreideanbau zugesetzt zwei prozent
weniger kuren als 2020 werden erwartet
und auch die getreidequalität leidet
unter der sommer nässe die
pilzkrankheiten begünstigt dagegen
profitierten mais zuckerrüben und gemüse
von den niederschlägen und stünden gut
da ein weiterer lichtblick für die
bauern sind die preise die deutlich
gestiegen sind
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
bei den deutschen hat sich in den
letzten wochen und monaten viel unmut
angestaut erst fehlten masken dann
impfstoff waren systeme für
katastrophenlagen funktionierte nicht
und jetzt das bittere ende des
afghanistan einsatzes und die
unfähigkeit den örtlichen helfern
sicherheit zu garantieren
der ganze politikbetrieb büßten deutlich
an ansehen ein auch die wahrnehmung der
wichtigsten probleme ändert sich
monatelang war es corona jetzt bringt
der klimawandel wieder nach vorn wer
soll angesichts dieser herausforderungen
das steuer im kanzleramt übernehmen
dass sich armin laschet dafür eignet
glaubt nur noch ein viertel der
befragten
71 prozent glauben das nicht über
weiteren auftrieb darf sich olaf scholz
freuen knapp zwei drittel halten ihn
inzwischen für kanzlertauglich 30
prozent nicht
22 prozent trauen es annalena baerbock
zu 74 prozent nicht
vor den ersten tv tree allen ist scholz
also der klare umfrage champion das
zeigt sich auch deutlich beim direkten
vergleich mit der konkurrenz vor die
wahl gestellt ob laschet scholz oder
baerbock merkel politisch beerben
sollten sagen nur noch 17 prozent der
befragten am liebsten laschet minus vier
prozentpunkte im vergleich zur letzten
umfrage
49 prozent entscheiden sich für scholz
+5 für baerbock sind es unverändert 16
prozent und 18 prozent wissen es nicht
die befragten stellen den meisten
politikerinnen und politikern ein
schlechtes zeugnis aus fast alle
verlieren an zustimmung manche sehr
deutlich die hier unsere top ten
sortiert nach sympathie und leistung auf
der skala von +5 bis -5
schlusslicht armin laschet minus 0,8
deutlich verschlechtert davor annalena
baerbock minus 0,5 etwas schlechter
platz acht für jens spahn minus 0,2
deutlich schlechter dann heiko maas
minus 0,2 dramatisch verschlechtert auf
platz sechs horst seehofer minus 0,1
deutliche verluste davor christian
lindner 0,0 auch er verliert robert
habeck 1,0 markus söder 1,2 beide etwas
schlechter auf platz 2 olaf scholz 1,5
etwas besser ganz von angela merkel 2,3
verschlechtert
reichlich bewegung gibt es auch in der
projektion
es zeichnet sich ein offener kampf darum
ab wer am ende stärkste kraft werden
wird wenn am nächsten sonntag wirklich
bundestagswahl wäre dann könnte die
union nur noch mit 22 prozent rechnen -
4 ihr schlechtester wert jemals im
politbarometer die spd läge bei 22
prozent plus 3 ihr bester wert seit fast
vier jahren die afg unverändert bei 11
prozent fdp 10 linke 6 prozent beide
minus 1 die grünen kämen auf 20 prozent
plus 1 und die freien wähler auf drei
prozent
damit hätten nur dreierbündnisse eine
regierungsmehrheit etwa die spd-geführte
ampel rot grün rot die deutschland
koalition oder eben auch jamaika der
endspurt zur wahl also so spannend wie
seit langem nicht fast neun von zehn
deutschen sagen es ist nicht klar wer
die wahl gewinnen wird
ob in afghanistan wahlen freiheit und
gleichberechtigung noch eine zukunft
haben es sieht düster aus der westen hat
sein ziel verfehlt das land demokratisch
zu stabilisieren die taliban haben im
handstreich die macht übernommen das
erreichte von 20 jahren steht jetzt auf
dem spiel
dass der militäreinsatz seit 2001
trotzdem grundsätzlich richtig war sagen
43 prozent genauso viele sehen das
anders
bei den anhängern von fdp linken und
freien wählern finden klare mehrheiten
den einsatz rückblickend falsch
durch die evakuierungs mission der
bundeswehr konnten tausende menschen aus
afghanistan gerettet werden es blieben
aber auch tausende zurück wie und ob
ihnen in zukunft noch geholfen werden
kann ist derzeit völlig offen
7 prozent sagen deutschland tut für die
rettung dieser kräfte zu viel
57 prozent meinen das ist zu wenig 27
prozent finden die hilfe so gerade
richtig
beim thema corona zeigt sich momentan
eine gewisse gelassenheit
die deutliche mehrheit der deutschen ist
mit den geltenden maßnahmen
einverstanden und blickt mit zuversicht
nach vorne trotz steigender
infektionszahlen
nur 31 prozent glauben dass die
krankenhäuser wieder ähnlich stark
belastet sein werden
63 prozent sind da optimistischer und
befürchten dass auch bei hohen
infektionszahlen nicht
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann
schon am dritten september bis zur
bundestagswahl im wöchentlichen rhythmus
nach dem wetter geht's hier heiter
weiter mit queens of comedy ihnen noch
einen entspannten abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend am dienstag ist der august
vorbei und damit auch der
meteorologische sommer bis dahin beehrt
uns dieses tief nick das dreht sich an
ort und stelle hier über polen über dem
östlichen deutschland und über
tschechien und bringt immer wieder
regenfälle mit aber kaum ist der
meteorologische herbst angefangen das
wird nämlich ab mittwoch der fall sein
wird dieses tief sich verabschieden und
richtung schwarzes meer wegziehen das
heißt wir bekommen es mit einem hoch zu
tun es gibt mehr sonnenschein und mehr
wärme mit diesen aussichten der tragen
wir das wochenende viel leichter heute
nach fällt häufig regen und die
temperaturen sinken auf 16 bis 7 grad
morgen bleibt es kühl bei uns mit 13 bis
18 grad am rhein steigen die werte
immerhin auf 19 bis 20 grad und morgen
fällt häufig regen und dieser regen ist
zum teil mit gewittern durchsetzt
chancen auf mehr sonnenschein haben sie
allenfalls im nördlichen schleswig
holstein
westlich des rheins und am oberrhein und
sehr wechselhaft geht es also auch
sonntag und montag weiter dienstag
kündigt sich hier im westen schon ein
bisschen eine wetterbesserung an viel
wärmer wird es dann aber wie sie hier am
trend für freiburg im breisgau sehen
können ab dem meteorologischen
herbstbeginn den ersten september dann
steigen die temperaturen verbreitet auf
20 bis vielleicht sogar 25 grad guten
abend